last Sunday's election in Hong Kong may
have been strictly local but it sent a
signal straight to the heart of mainland
China in the face of an increasingly
violent standoff between trona Mok recei
protesters and Hong Kong's Beijing
backed government a record number of
voters turned out for the poll and
handed a landslide victory to
pro-democracy candidates for the city's
local District Council's the resounding
defeat took Hong Kong's beleaguered
government by surprise and up to the
pressure on Beijing will that make a
crackdown on the protesters more
difficult or more likely Hong Kong
elections wake-up call for Beijing
that's our topic
[Music]
welcome to to the point we've invited
three highly knowledgeable guests to
exchange views on what the Hong Kong
election result could mean hang Xuan Lee
born in Hong Kong works for five years
at Deutsche Welle as a TV reporter and
also on our China desk and she says what
happens in Hong Kong should be a wake-up
call for the whole world the Chinese
regime is a danger to all free societies
bannout Barch
is an Asian expert with Germany's
renowned battles Mun Foundation and he
says Beijing's reaction to pressure is
counter pressure not only Hong Kong will
feel it but also the West and it's a
pleasure to welcome glaciar pong she is
a Hong Kong native a digital rights and
political activist she's currently
studying in Hamburg Germany her position
the opposition might have won the
election but not yet the fight for human
rights the system is broken the fight
can't stop here and it can't stop now so
let me start out by asking the two of
you hung Kuen and also glacier what you
are hearing from friends and family at
home what's their reaction to the
election results they were very
surprised because it was a landslide
victory and they didn't expect that they
expect the Democrats will well gain a
little more power but not that much
so they were very happy and they also
expressed a lot of yeah they express the
views on online for examples and for my
friends say well most of the protein of
the protesters are actually still under
18 ad and they still can't vote and if
they could have more than the results
could have been like even it could have
been a more even bigger victory for the
Democrats so that sounds like a pretty
upbeat reaction how about in the case of
your friends and family glacier what are
they saying my friends are actually very
surprised about the results as well but
they're a little bit more pessimistic
they were saying that oh now we have won
the district council so now what what do
we do up next and what everybody just
thinks because we have won two district
council election that
movement is over many friends are kind
of worried about that people would have
the presumption that because we won the
district council then that's it for the
movement we have achieved everything won
but it's actually not the case so more
or less they're a bit pessimistic but
they're still very happy about actually
at least we show the world most of the
majority are in support of the pen
democratic parties and you yourself
clearly have an opinion you say the
protest can and should go on I'm not
saying that the protests have to go on
like definitely but we have to continue
to fight for a basic human rights for
example the right to run for office the
right to vote for our leaders in our
government I think this is what I mean
by the protest should go on we cannot
stop here because even though we won in
this system but the system itself is
already problematic and broken so we
need to fix that before we can go any
further in that so they're not it sounds
to me if I put that statement together
with your own opening statement that
Beijing will sustain or even increase
the pressure as if we're not likely to
see any real climb down from the stand
down of the past once
I'm afraid that's what's going to happen
I think this is actually much more than
a wake-up call because the alarm bells
have been ringing for six months so this
is more the ice bucket that you get if
you really read on't get out of bed the
question is does Beijing understand that
the path that they've followed for the
last six month just hasn't worked and
that they've totally underestimated the
the resolve of the Hong Kong people and
that they've kind of believed too much
their own propaganda because as far as I
know Beijing has been taken totally by
surprise by this by this result let's
listen to what some of the protesters
had to say after the election results to
get a few more impressions about what
people are saying in Hong Kong
some would believe that we have won the
election the people have won but I don't
think this is what we really wanted
ultimately what we want her is
the good laws to be enforced and the law
enforcers should be free doing the job
rather than just standing on the
opposite side of the people I think the
stuff from everything to be honest light
for the future life for the protester if
it goes well and if the doesn't burn
pretty well I think the protests will
just go down like peacefully otherwise
just gonna go off it all depends on how
the kauffman gonna provide this riccati
election is already that the facto
referendum to prove how long people
deserve free election when more than 70
or almost 80% of people vote in election
why can't Hong Kong people get back the
right to elected our government we are
not satisfied only elect the district
councillors so as we heard there much is
riding on what the Hong Kong government
does next let's hear what the leader the
embattled Carrie Lam had to say
following the election we have
officially and formally withdrawn the
bill which was of course of all these
social unrest the next step to go
forward is really as you have put it to
engage the people and we have started
public dialogue with the community but
unfortunately with the unstable
environment and the chaotic situation I
could not do more of that sort of
engagement I hope that the the
environment will allow me to do it now
when Carrie Lam and other members of the
establishment in Hong Kong were as
surprised as I guess your families were
as well apparently they had been
expecting that the election would reveal
widespread protests fatigue among
ordinary citizens instead it did reflect
this widespread sympathy for the
pro-democracy movement where does that
leave Carrie Lam I think she's really
embattled right now because it was just
like Krishna Wong has said it was like a
referendum and it clearly shows that
that Hong Kong people really want the
protest to go on and that their demands
should be should be much and that leaves
her in a very difficult position because
of course she has to listen to Beijing
as well
because she can't just say okay let's
meet the demands people glacier would
you have expected Carrie lamb to be more
conciliatory than what we heard there
and do you think we me it may still see
her make significant concessions it
wouldn't be the first time that she has
backed down I don't think she would have
the approval for Beijing to back down
because backing down would make both the
Hong Kong government and the Beijing
government look kind of ridiculous on
the global arena because China has
always used strong hand approach to deal
with all descendants in China or in Hong
Kong before so we I don't expect to see
Kerry lamb or the Beijing government to
back down for a bit I think they will
have to I think they will approach a
wait-and-see approach for the next week
and see how does the peaceful assembly
is going on next week and then they will
decide but I think if the government is
not escalating again or if they can stop
the police from police brutality then
maybe there is a little room for a scale
down of the protests but I also think
that the vessels actually show that most
of the Hongkongers feel that the use of
force by the protesters is actually more
or less legitimate or at least can be
justified because I think the police and
the government has already lost his
legitimacy to rule and to protect a
citizens property or their life because
in July for example in June long the MTR
station when the trade members attack
innocent passerby the police were not
there and when parole establishment
supporters were attacking passerby or
those who were only doing peaceful
protesters taking up Lenin walls the
police were not there and the system
cannot hold the police responsible for
their wrongdoings and that's why
Hongkongers peaceful protesters and also
the radical processors are very hard to
be divided because they see the need of
use of force to make them feel safe or
at least feel like that let's come back
to the use of force in just a moment
because we do have a little report about
that but I first like to try to read the
tea leaves in Beijing if possible about
hot so the Chinese government's initial
response to this election result was
quite muted what do you think we can
interpret from that what will be going
on right now in Beijing I
they are reorganizing because they were
totally surprised and they didn't expect
that this movement would really have
such wide support from the from the Hong
Kong public and I think what they'll try
to do now is get a feeling for is there
something where they can negotiate a
couple of years ago when the umbrella
movement was the the big demonstration
in Hong Kong there were actually some
offers from begging side towards some
changes to the electoral system I don't
think that's on the table again now but
I hope at least that they're
reconsidering their position yeah I
think I don't think this is this would
make Beijing feeling the pressure that
they need to reform the electoral system
actually it would suggest the otherwise
because the government and Beijing now
knows if it's full démocratique election
they will lose for sure even though
they're from the general figures we can
see that the pro-democracy camp can only
have 60 percent of support from Hong
Kong us but that's more than enough
that's already the majority I think
Beijing sees the danger of giving full
democracy to Hong Kong because it means
they will lose total control over Hong
Kong so I really don't think it would be
the chance for Beijing to see oh maybe
we should do a reform because it wants
to tighten its control over Hong Kong
yeah I agree and also Beijing will not
do that because even if Beijing is
backing down then it means that the
protest
we've seen which has turned violent
recently that means that works so it
won't happen that Beijing will back down
let me ask you a little bit more about
Carrie lambswool because Carrie Lam of
course is the conduit for Beijing in in
Hong Kong so on Monday interestingly
enough leaders of the main pro-beijing
party were televised bowing collectively
in a public apology a pro Beijing Labor
Federation blamed Carrie Lam for their
groups losses in the election that
sounds like she is deeply discredited on
both sides both visa vie Hong Kong
citizens but also the
the Beijing itself so what would you
expect to be her fate going forward I
think of fate to be going forward will
be it would be a very difficult
situation for her because you've already
framed it very good she's in a position
where she doesn't get support from any
parties not from the pro-democracy side
not from the pro-establishment camp and
not from Beijing as well of course
Beijing says they will support her but
she has to listen to Carrie Lam has to
listen to Beijing and that's making her
very difficult to stay in her own
actually so question to you glacier are
there credible alternatives to Carrie
Lam bearing in mind that her term as as
far as I know only goes until 2022 is
that correct
and in fact these district councils they
do not really have much say in larger
politics but there is a committee on
which members are represented that will
have a say in the next chief executive
so my question to you would be are there
credible alternatives to Carrie Lam who
perhaps could find a middle path that
she hasn't found I haven't seen any
credible political figures in Hong Kong
that would be able to resolve the
political turmoil because this political
term oh I will not only this six months
but also the those before the smaller
scales for example the umbrella
revolution or the ones before these are
saying no this is signaling there is
something very wrong with the system
fundamentally there is something wrong
with one country two systems' even
because that was supposed to be a
temporal solution to the problem of
handing off back handing over to China
but this system it's not a very stable
and long-term solution for Hong Kong and
China so actually the signals there has
to be something fundamental going on
with the system itself to be able to
resolve all the political turmoil that
has been accumulating since maybe 2003
so I but I don't see any figures that
are strong enough or powerful capable
enough to stand out and say okay let's
do it
that sort that way and I believe that
Democratics fully democratic system is
the only way out of this any chance
whatsoever that Beijing would ever agree
to that we're now talking
about the difference between in a sense
the short term that we've seen in the
protests that we've seen in these
clashes and the much longer term namely
the ultimate goal of China that Hong
Kong would be fused into a larger China
is there any any chance at all that that
ultimate goal for I think it's 2047
would ever be adjusted I'm really sad to
say I see no chance at all I think
there's no alternative to fighting for
it but in the current political climate
in Beijing this is not going to happen
the only hope that there is is that
there will be a phase after he Jinping
that the Hong Kong situation shows that
there are many things wrong with Hong
Kong and with with with China it's they
didn't see what was coming up in Hong
Kong there are so many other issues it's
not going very well for Xi Jinping and
the Communist Party the hope would be
that they go back to a reform path and
see that they are paying a high price
for this for the time being Hong Kong is
paying the price but there's a much
bigger price to pay and that's coming
home to roost for baking so that fight
for human rights let's come back now to
the question of the protests and the
violence after increasingly violent
confrontations between protesting
students and police Hong Kong actually
has been pretty quiet this week with the
protesters holding off for now to see
how the government responds but they
have left little doubt that they are
ready to resume let's take a look
[Music]
the violent confrontations in Hong Kong
hit a new extreme when police stormed
university buildings leading to numerous
injuries on both sides right from the
start the special operations brigades
have been taking ever more drastic
measures to get the protests under
control including tear gas meanwhile the
protesters rage is boiling over and the
reluctance to strike back is evaporating
on top of the police brutality the Hong
Kong government's refusal to consider
the demands of millions of citizens is
especially frustrating to the
demonstrators and growing numbers of
young activists are left with the
impression that peaceful protests will
achieve nothing more and more resorting
to violence but frustration can all too
easily become blind destructive rage
what kind of violence is justified in
the struggle for democracy glaciar let
me pass that question right on to you
how much violence is justified under the
circumstances I think it depends on
really depends on each context if you
are living in a fully functional
democratic country of course violence is
in no way justified but for in Hong Kong
the situation is a bit different like in
June two million people nearly a quarter
of the population march in the street
peacefully but then the government
simply repeated with no tit and that's
it and it refuses to listen all along
the way we try to make dialogues but the
government simply just ignored us so I
read a slogan on the Legislative Council
on on the news when people stormed into
it it says it's you who taught me that
peaceful protest doesn't work and I
really feel how upset or frustrated
protesters are and I think because
protesters in Hong Kong is now feels
like that the police or the government
are not able to protect them as I have
said that's why they very sought to use
the usual force nobody would like that
actually it's actually very dangerous
and it's very frustrating and tiring at
the same time I think most Hong Kong
people would enjoy their life peacefully
and quietly but they feel like that the
government has left them with no choice
because they never listen when we try to
go into the system in 2016 Canada Scot
from running and it is even this time in
the district council election Joshua
Wong was banned from running for office
in his district and it actually shows
that the system doesn't work even though
you enter the system you can be
disqualified as legislators and another
thing is I don't think Hongkongers or
the so-called violent protesters are
attacking instructing Zoar people
randomly they actually have specific
targets and well justified reasons
behind that for example they go into MTR
stations because before the MTR has
allowed the police to go in and they
have deterred first aid assistants and
they have helped the police to cover up
what is happening inside Prince Edward
station so I feel like it's more or less
justify to yes
let me ask Conklin if she also sees it
that way and in view of what Bernhard
told us that he doesn't see this regime
in Beijing backing down from the long
term goal which precludes democracy in
Hong Kong are we basically seeing a
generation of young people who may wind
up giving their lives or at least their
future chances to this fight they are
already doing this because when they go
onto the streets right now and protest
they risks to be getting arrested and
once they get arrested they could be
charged and the terms can be update they
could be jailed up to ten years and they
are already doing this and I've also
spoken to some protesters very young
protesters and what they've been telling
me is that they are willing to do this
because they feel that they are young
enough and even if they get into jail
for ten years when they come out they
are still young and that's why they are
doing this for people who are now over
maybe twenty and twenty something
because they feel like they still have
to use to do this and this is this is
very sad to me to listening to that that
they are trying to sacrifice themselves
they're not ever since the protests
began there's been a lot of speculation
about whether Beijing would eventually
authorize the Tiananmen Square type
crackdown in other words a violent
repression of the protests now surely
this election result discredits Beijing
as well as Carrie Lam does that make a
crackdown more
or less likely no medium term I would
hope it makes it less likely I don't
think it would work in Hong Kong because
this is not like Chinamen a central
square with a lot of people the protests
dissolve and and evaporate that's this
this water metaphor that Hong Kong
protesters have have used I don't think
nowadays we're the technological means
that baiting has you need a crackdown
with tanks I'm very pessimistic though
about whether Beijing is going to give
the protesters more room I think they're
slowly working their way through the
ranks and putting pressure on them with
every possible means and I'm afraid in
some ways this is going to work because
they're making people's lives help so
how would you answer the question that
was at the end of our report just now
how much violence is legitimate under
such circumstances I don't think the
violence has done the protest the great
service you know better how to negotiate
with your own governments from a foreign
perspective this has really undermined
the narrative and it has given the big
propaganda present to Beijing because
they could argue look at this violence I
think the the more subtle means
gathering in malls and singing glory to
Hong Kong is is much more effective and
much more subtle and makes it much more
easier for foreign governments to
support this not only towards Hong Kong
but also in their communications with
Beijing let me ask precisely to the
point of foreign governments what you
think the outside world should be doing
Hong Xuan said the election is a wake-up
call to the whole world what would you
want to see other countries other powers
doing I think other countries should
seeing the case of Hong Kong or even in
other parts of China for example in the
western part of China the wiggers what
they're what they have been suffering
withers are the ethnic minorities in
China and there recently there have been
leaks that showing that proving that
that they are
under the so called ethnic genocide some
people with describing essentially being
held in concentration camps yes exactly
and so I think the case in Hong Kong and
also in Xinjiang for example really
shows that how how Beijing is governing
its cities or other places and I think
the whole work should now really look
into this and say no that's not going to
work this way and if you want to defend
human rights that that's the point right
now that's time right now to do this and
if you wait for another five or ten
years who knows what China will grow
into so glacier the u.s. just has passed
in relation not only to Hong Kong but
also the you igor's
a Hong Kong human rights and democracy
act that with sanction officials
responsible for human rights violations
and also makes economic relations with
Hong Kong conditional on the US
Secretary of State certifying that Hong
Kong remains autonomous from China would
you say that kind of pressure is helpful
and should there be more of it for
example also from Europe from Germany I
think it's very really helpful because
right after the bill is passed in both
of the parliaments and the US the
Chinese authorities were furious seven
different organizations from the
authority have spoken as like a combo
they keep saying that they regret the
bill was passing something like that and
I think if the European Union or Germany
will at least propose some legislature
or some policies like that this kind of
gesture showing that we are not going to
tolerate Chinese violation of human
rights would be very helpful in terms of
the Hong Kong situation or those ethnic
minorities in China because it's it's a
really good show of gesture saying that
we are actually closely monitoring and
we may will take action the situation
worsens and hard there's a lot of
concern here in Germany also in Europe
in general that the US and China have
come engaged in a standoff that almost
resembles a new Cold War and I often
hear voices in Germany saying we have to
find a middle way in this case does Hong
Kong do the Igor's show us that Germany
needs to take a much stronger position
I think it's right that we have to find
some
of middle way because we just don't
we're not the actor on the global stage
that the u.s. is but I think everyone
agrees that at the end we are on the
western side of things if we are forced
to take sides then we are of course we
stand with Western values the question
is are we being forced and issues like
Hong Kong and chin Jiang do put this
force on us and that is good because it
it forces us to make big decisions
let me ask all of you very briefly where
basically at the end of our time wake up
call to Beijing will it be heard and not
only there but in other countries yes or
no yes yes oh okay well that's consensus
thank you very much to all of you for
being with us
and thanks to you out there for tuning
in see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]